there was a very nice moment at a Pete
Buddha judge rally this week a young boy
asked Buddha jej who is the only openly
gay presidential candidate if he would
help the boy come out as gay yeah it was
really powerful take a look the next
question comes from Zachary aged 9 he
says thank you for being so brave would
you help me tell the world I'm gay too
I want to be brave like you I can
promise you that I'm gonna be rooting
for you and I think there's a whole
bunch of people here who are gonna be
ready to have his back it was really
incredibly yeah it was sweet very
heartwarming really nice to see that
it's so touching to see role models
helping the younger generation
especially those in marginalized groups
excuse me Conan oh yeah hey buddy
someone get this kid a microphone give
him a microphone yeah hi Conan I really
look up to you and since you're the only
late-night host like me can you help me
come out okay well okay I just you need
to know I'm not yay oh I know I mean
help me come out as a huge dork
well I had to be honest I don't know if
that's what I am I think it's so brave
of you to be on TV even though the whole
world is begging you not to even that's
not really the case you have everything
going against you your hair is insane
the color of your skin can only be
described as printer paper and you have
the sex appeal of the Slender Man okay
we we get it okay we a you understand
you what you say I'm not done your work
you're weird gangly body for to begin I
can't tell where your torso stops in
your ankles start and yet you don't let
any of those disabilities stop you you
know these are not disabilities by the
way not to mention you have the courage
to host alongside someone as cool as
Andy yeah I don't know how he does it
sorry I'm sorry what was the point of
your question again shut up Dork and let
him finish
Conan please they weren't inspiration to
dorks like me I'm obviously not as big
of a dork as you that's impossible
so please we help me tell my friends and
family in front of this whole audience
today that I'm a dork to do it do
fine everyone the kid here is a dork
just like me
you